what do you think in terms of its
potential kind of take down avatar can
it become the highest grossing movie of
all time not going to make any
predictions at all we're excited by what
we know of it what we've seen we cannot
wait to show it to the world and I think
it would be best just to stop right
there I wish you were coming out
tomorrow because I can't wait for
everybody to see it but I think it's way
too premature to start making any
predictions except what we do know based
on the interest in the trailer how much
interest there is in this film yeah for
sure a lot of interests involved are you
in that process I mean will you for
example I'll be looking at this before
it's released well I have the luxury of
having some tremendous talent in terms
of our executive team that leads these
great divisions and that's certainly
true with the studio but something is
big and is important to Star Wars you
know I will be interested and i will use
some of my time and express my interest
by you know being involved in the
process of varying degrees along the way
but we all rely on great movie makers in
this case JJ Abrams and a great team of
writers and producers and I rely on a
great team in our Studios you know again
with Alan horn but I guess the answer
your question straightforward is I will
see it before it comes out probably a
couple of times okay oh why not right I
have that right that's way if it works
of the job right as well um when you
think about our ride rides my ride rides
before they're open to it's a good deal
but speaking of rides actually how are
you gonna incorporate Star Wars into the
theme parks well we've got Star Wars
attractions at a number of our parks
they're called Star Tours and we are
developing plans right now that we've
talked about publicly but have not
announced specifically for substantial
increase in Star Wars presence in
multiple places
around the world including disneyland in
anaheim and Disney World in Orlando and
in all likelihood you'll see it in
Shanghai and possibly Tokyo and Hong
Kong as well so we've got big plans our
Imagineers are hard at work at drawing
them up and fairly soon I'm sure we'll
be ready to go public with some
specifics but you it's safe to say that
you'll see a lot more Star Wars at
Disney and at Disney parks in the near
future